by a majority this court allows the
appeal on the issue of whether Rwanda is
a safe Third Country it's a ruling that
human rights groups have welcomed and
it's thrown the British government's
entire scheme for deporting Asylum
Seekers to Rwanda into doubt the latest
appeal was brought by the charity Asylum
Aid and 10 Asylum Seekers all arrived in
the UK by crossing the English Channel
from France the key issue was whether
Rwanda was a safe Third Country to send
them to the Court's answer was no
by a majority of two to one judges here
ruled that if people were deported to
Rwanda they could then be sent on to
their country of origin where they face
persecution or other inhumane treatments
even though they had a good case for
Asylum
much of the evidence in the appeal
hearing came from the United Nations
Refugee agency the unhcr were absolutely
clear that the Asylum system in Rwanda
is nascent there are material
deficiencies it is under-resourced the
staff have not had adequate training and
they're a systemic bias prime minister
Rishi sunak has made stopping the boats
one of his priorities
he's currently trying to pass
legislation allowing authorities to
detain and Deport anyone making the
dangerous sea Journey apart from
unaccompanied children
opposition politicians say the
government should concentrate on cutting
a huge aside in claims backlog which has
left thousands of vulnerable people in
limbo the government standing firm we
are currently spending as I say six
million pounds a day on Hotel
accommodation three billion pounds a
year on servicing our Asylum costs those
costs are unsustainable and the Prime
Minister and I have made it clear that
we will do whatever it takes to stop the
boats and fix this problem the UK
government's hoping to appeal the latest
ruling at the Supreme Court more delays
and uncertainty and for those Asylum
Seekers affected more distress
compounding their trauma they're having
to wait yes in some cases over a year
with nothing happening on their cases
they're not even starting the process of
having their Asylum claims considered
and that comes on the back of often very
traumatic Journeys to the UK and fleeing
obviously persecution War torture
besides the ongoing legal fees Britain's
already spent almost 180 million dollars
on the Rwanda scheme a scheme that shows
no signs are being implemented in the
near future Nadine barber Al Jazeera
London